ebacks and the nationals the rubber game
on this sunday afternoon
andrew d back started today the
right-hander luke weaver who flat out
dominated in a win over the marlins last
monday
after saying about all his struggles
this year enough was enough
enough was enough and we talked about
him having a chip on his shoulder you
see what he did last monday against the
marlins he gave it four
runs in four innings against these
nationals earlier this year so
use that as motivation today leads the
nationals with seven stolen bases
he leads the nationals at pretty much
everything
popped it up way up there third base for
escobar
we were trying to set the side down in
order here in the opening inning
the o2 pitch and it's swung out and
missed elevated fastball
at 95 and zimmerman slams the bat down
lays the helmet next to it
weavers got a one two three first
d-backs face eric fetty bottom of the
first
betty very effective in facing the
diamondbacks april
17th in washington when five innings
gave up just a run on four hits had nine
strikeouts
that's belted into right rojas continues
his red hot
play at the plate it's a one-ounce
single it was just no slowing him down
i mean getting good pitches to hit 94 up
over the heart of the plate
josh doesn't miss it he steps in now
against fetty with a man on and a man
out shift on the right side and he
swings
a little blooper that is going to be
caught on the run on a nice play
and the out is recorded and back to
first hustle's
rojas one down that was caught by castro
the third baseman
ross with a one out single at first two
down and there's a high chopper to
second
and mercer fields and soft tosses to
first to zimmerman to retire
peralta going down the line and then the
ending no runs one hit one left after
one he puts zimmerman away with a high
fastball
let's see what he's got for castro
steven vogt back there
let's see some attitude with this one
it's working for luke weaver
five up and five down i like that you
saw steven boat pump his fist before he
even gave the sign
give me your best fastball right here
luke shook off the location
he wanted to go away rather than inside
and
close it right by castro that time
here's the 2-2 pitch
and a ground ball to the right side
smith can't get it
domingo labo does and weaver's over
there to cover they get the out
that'll end the ending that play will go
4-1
to get the slow footed availa at first
base signed an order again for weaver
stephen vogt leads off the bottom of the
second against eric finney
swinging a fly ball to left center hit
it pretty well back of the warning track
and back of the wall and it's off the
wall extra bases
schwarber gets it back in and standing
at second base with a lead off double
his vote and he just missed the home run
out there
just missed in fact i thought it might
go once i was
saw schwarber kind of stop i was
surprised it actually hit the wall
so for vote that's his third double nice
start to the inning
and an rbi chance for domingo laba
against the start at second base
recalled from reno the other day still
two and two
this will back up robles in center
votes at second and he's not even going
to think about it
you don't want to mess with that arm
it's pretty good out there
3-2 pitch and ahmed are grounded is
short bone hustles back to second
turner throws to first to zimmerman
ahmed's return and that's out number two
in the inning
don't want to waste that lead off double
stephen vogt still down there at second
now with two outs
on the way to la castro and tim swing
sets it down to third
and castro's got it guns the first just
ahead of the speedy la castro
two on the eddy no runs a leadoff double
man left on base will go to the top of
the third here in phoenix
long hold at the belt roble is running
the pitch is in the dirt vote throws
down to second anyway and it's too late
robles almost came off the bag with the
feet first slide popping up but he's
able to hold on to the base
with his left foot as he has stolen base
number four
count two and one his vote did a pretty
amazing job to dig that ball out of dirt
and
get rid of it like it was no big deal
he's only made five appearances
soria has given up four runs on eight
hits in four and two thirds innings
now the pitch swinging a little looping
line drive toward the middle i'm at
leaps and then the second baseman ley
but dives and neither one can get it
schwarber takes a wide turn they throw
him behind him and the tag is not
made so schwarber safe at first
almost got thrown out by lo castro after
the wide turn
able to make a leaping superman dive to
avoid the outstretched arm of pavin
that's have a leadoff man on for the
second consecutive inning
long look and the pitch swinging to miss
he struck him out
casser went fishing didn't get it first
out of the inning
and now alex sevilla they hit her nice
combo of pitches there comes back with
the change up over the top
and castro pulls way off of that on the
way
and a fly ball getting into the left
peralta goes back schwarber goes back to
tag there's a catch by david
throw comes back in and schwarber will
hold his ground at second base two outs
in the inning
here's jordy mercer who got the start at
sega base today twice he's grounded out
to ahmed at short
the pitch swing and a miss strike him
out fast ball up
didn't get it no runs one hit
under stranded in scoring position laba
fly ball to center
ground ball to mercer at second
and a ball hit hard that's how you get a
quick guy turner
in the middle 4-6-3 looks like laba's
helmet hit ryan zimmerman
on his way by that's turned their 30th
double play of the year
and now nick ahmed will step to the
plate the short stop nothing nothing
bottom of the seventh
fetty rocks kicks throws swinging a
ground ball chopped to shore turner
reaches down to his left
whirls all the way around and fires to
first to get his man
and eric fetty for the first time in his
big league career has finished off
seven shutout innings no runs no hits a
walker
here's a pinch hitter off the bench for
davey martinez pitcher spot leads off
the eighth then it's yadiel hernandez
the left-hand banner
the pitch swung on and into the air down
the left field line toward the corner
this one deep
and into the diamondbacks bullpen it is
gone goodbye
an opposite field home run down the left
field line for yada
hernandez and just like that
on a 1-0 pitch from stephon crichton
bang zoom goes yadiel hernandez with a
pinch hit
opposite field home run it's his second
home run of the year
and the nationals are on the board now
the top of the order and turner
rio green light high chopper base in
robles coming around third he's going to
score
two two-nothing just like that and trey
turner speeds into second base
and kyle schwarber the batter with two
out
that's pretty aggressive ryan zimmerman
chugging for home
the throw is cut off in the next lead
three-nothing swing and a miss on a big
hook
brad hand on the road back the way you
like it
no suspense in the ninth inning a one
two three for the next closure